[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAN CIRULI: Hi, everyone.
Welcome, everybody.
I told you I'd be louder
than I thought I would be.
My name is Dan Ciruli
and I'm joined here
by Sep Ebrahimzadeh.
Not bad, right?
Welcome to the last session
of Google Cloud Next.
This is for you guys.
I predicted when I saw the
schedule that we would have
no one in the last session.
So I'm very, very impressed
at every one of you
for actually making it.
And before we get
started, I want
to thank the people
in the back, who've
been working really hard.
They're the only ones
who work really hard
in this whole thing.
Thank you, guys,
for all your work.
[APPLAUSE]
So, Sep and I are here today
to talk about authenticating
service to service calls
with Google Cloud Endpoints,
and that's what you
guys are here for.
Right?
Yeah.
OK.
Who won a drone?
Anyone win a drone in this room?
Anyone win anything good
down there on the floor?
Nothing.
Oh, Sep, did you bring prizes?
SEP EBRAHIMZADEH: I did.
Whoever stays till the end
of the talk will get a prize.
DAN: [CHUCKLES] OK.
Besides the prizes
that we don't have,
this is what we're going
to be talking about today.
First, I'm going to get
started by talking a little bit
about the difference
between authentication
and authorization to make
clear what we're talking about.
We are talking about
authentication today
and I just want to be
clear on what that means.
And I want to talk
about real scenarios,
and why this matters
to you, and where
you might be already
needing this,
where you might be
using it, or where
you might use it in the future.
I do want to talk about
Cloud Endpoints itself
for a little while.
I don't like to make
product pitches,
but this is a product that's
undergone a bunch of changes
in the last year,
and I want to make
sure you guys are all up to
speed on where we are right
now.
But then we're going to spend
the bulk of the session in that
let's get to it bullet point.
This is a 200 level session.
I don't know what that
means to you guys,
but to me it means you
get to see some code.
So Sep's going to
come up on stage
and he's going to show you
exactly how you configure
endpoints to secure your
APIs, and exactly what you
need to do to generate
calls to make those.
And we should leave plenty
of time at the end for Q&A
and get you out the door on time
so everybody makes their plane
back to Moscow tonight.
Not tonight, probably.
OK.
So, authentication
versus authorization.
Those of you who came
in here on an airplane
when you got to an
airport somewhere,
you had to produce a
passport, and that passport
is identification.
And it is used, essentially,
to authenticate you.
An authentication
token is a token
that is generated by
someone that we trust,
an authority that we trust,
and positively identifies
an individual or an API call.
And it's different
than authorization.
An authentication
just says this is me.
It's like your identification.
This is me and this is who I am.
It alone doesn't enable
you to do things,
but then it can be
used to authorize you.
So for example, if you've
got that in a visa,
you might be allowed
to enter a country.
If you've got a driver's
license, that identifies you.
It's authentication,
but it also authorizes
you to operate a motor vehicle
in the state of California.
So what we're talking today
is about authentication,
and the key thing to note
there is that you cannot do
authorization if you
haven't done authentication.
I can't decide if you're allowed
to walk through that door right
now if you don't have a badge
on that tells me who you are.
So today we're going to be
talking about authentication.
Now.
When might you use this?
Well, how many people have
developed mobile APIs?
How many have mobile apps?
Those mobile apps make calls
back to an API frequently.
That's one of the
primary use cases
that we've seen for endpoints
over the last couple of years.
But what we've learned in
talking to our customers is
that they've got a mobile
API, and that's-- we'll talk
a little bit about
user auth later.
But behind that, almost
always, more frequently
than we thought, there
are other services.
That mobile API that received
that call from the mobile app
is then making calls to
other backend systems.
So there are ways to
authenticate users
and we'll talk a little
bit about them later.
But you've got something
in your mobile app that's
going to generate a
credential and you
want to send that
over to your backend,
and have that thing
validate that auth token,
and validate that you
know who the user is
that made that call.
But the issue is, that token
that was generated to make that
call, most frequently,
you don't want
that to be the kind
of authentication
that you use on those other--
that your mobile API is calling.
You actually would like those
services to reject that token.
And the reason you
want to do that
is that you don't want that
guy, who has the ability
to get a hold of
one of those tokens,
to be able to call
your backend systems.
Generally, they're backend
systems for a reason,
and you don't intend for them
to be exposed externally.
You don't want
people calling them.
So you need actually to
have different on auth
than you do on
that front end API.
And if you're using App
Engine, or App Engine Flexible
Environments, all of
those IP addresses
are visible from the internet.
And so you need something
to be able to protect it
and to take a different
auth token then
you're sending from
your mobile app.
Anyone has ever heard
the word microservices?
Yes, you've been
in this industry
for the last two years.
You hear it four times a day.
You look at hacker news.
People talk about
it a lot and we
have a lot of customers
who are implementing them.
We didn't use the term
microservices at Google,
but at Google we've been
doing this for a decade or so.
And quite famously,
internally at Google,
we have a flat network.
We don't protect resources
from other resources
via the network.
Everything can address
everything else.
However, every single call
that we make on our network
is made with
authentication tokens
so that we can identify which
service is making a call,
and we can validate yes, that
is a caller that I trust.
And the other time you
might be doing this,
and something we're seeing
a lot with endpoints today,
is customers who are not just
developing services in Google,
and maybe GCE, maybe GKE,
GAE, and not just in Google,
but they're also running
things on premises
and they're developing
services that
need to contact each
other, whether it's
calling from GCP back to
their on premises services,
or calling from their on
premises services up to GCE.
Some people attempt to
put security in here
with networking, but that
can be very difficult.
And if you are
exposing IPs, it's
critical that you can
authenticate those calls.
And it gets more
complicated than this,
and it's almost hard
to believe but I'm
told that we have customers
who are running services
in the middle of the Amazon.
Sounds unbelievable,
but it's true.
And again, there, it can
be more difficult to solve
this security problem with
any sort of networking issue.
Setting up firewalls
that can help you
cloud to cloud and on
premise is very difficult.
So it's just another
situation where
you want to be able authenticate
who your callers are.
So that's a bunch of reasons
why you need service to service
authentication today.
Now I want to talk a little
bit about Cloud Endpoints
before Sep shows us how it
can solve all your problems.
So how many people have used
Cloud Endpoints in the past two
years?
Well, you might know it
as a feature of App Engine
because that's what it
was for a couple of years.
It was a Java framework
and a Python framework
that you could
use in App Engine.
It had a few different features,
but was limited to Java,
Python, and App Engine.
Well, ever since last fall,
and now generally available,
we have really added a
lot to the feature set.
And first of all, we
made it so it's not just
an App Engine feature anymore.
This is a product
in cloud that can
be used with any of
our compute backends.
And it's not just used
as an API framework,
but it's got these additional
features that let you protect,
monitor, and scale your APIs.
So one of the key components is
what we call a distributed API
gateway, and this
is an architecture
that we've been
using at Google now
for a couple of
years for our APIs.
We used to have an API
proxy and every call
that you made to
www.googleapis.com
went through a proxy.
And that did things like
authentication, and monitoring,
and logging, and we used all
those systems internally.
But we found that the extra
network hop added latency
and dealing with lots
and lots of configuration
that this thing had to know
about was difficult as well.
So we moved to an architecture
where our proxy is actually
a very thin proxy that gets
deployed with each backend.
So instead of having a fat
proxy that sits in the middle
and does a bunch of work
and then forwards calls,
we deploy, in a container
with each backend, the proxy.
So calls can get routed
directly to the backend
and the proxy can perform
that same work there.
We find that it's very, very
performant, and very scalable.
Endpoints is an open source.
It's based on Nginx, which
is an open sourced proxy
and uses that same architecture.
It sits on top of the same
services we use for our APIs.
Endpoints is also deeply
integrated with GCP.
So if you're using our
App Engine frameworks,
it's built in.
If you're using App Engine
Flexible Environment,
our proxy is built in.
If you're using GKE,
we have a container
that you can drop
into your deployment,
and of course, you can take our
proxy and drop it on GCE too.
So it's deeply integrated
with the backend.
It also sends all of
your monitoring metrics
to Google Cloud Console
where you have dashboards.
It sends all of your logs
to Stackdriver logging.
It uses Stackdriver Trace.
For people who are
developing on Google
and developing new applications,
whatever language you're using,
it can add these features that
we're going to show today.
So we're talking about
authentication today,
and as I mentioned, it
also does good logging.
And I think Sep is
going to show you
a little bit about what the
monitoring looks like later on.
And it's very, very scalable,
and it's also very performant.
We find that, at
scale, it tends to add
less than a millisecond of
latency to your API requests.
Many competing solutions add one
or even two orders of magnitude
more than that.
And again, to emphasize, this
is not an App Engine feature
anymore.
You can use it with any language
on any of our compute backends.
Google functions coming soonish.
So this is kind of what the
architecture looks like.
You can place your
calls from anywhere.
Here, we show them
from an Android app,
an iOS app, a browser.
Of course, it can
be another service,
but all of your web traffic
is routed through this proxy.
Its an Nginx based
proxy, and that's
the proxy that
actually does the work
and decides whether or
not a call gets through.
That thing receives config from
a service we call the Google
Service Management API.
And then at runtime its checking
in with something called
the service control API, and
that's the thing that's saying,
hey, is this API key
valid, or can this project
call your project.
And its also reporting your
metrics to Google Cloud logging
and that's the thing that sends
the data up to the dashboard.
When calls go through they
get forward to your backend,
and if a call is rejected,
say it's not authenticated,
it never gets to your backend.
About a year and a half ago
when we really started saying,
hey, we want to handle any
language, it was clear to us
that we needed an IDL that
could describe these APIs.
When we stepped away
from the framework world,
we need a way for you to tell us
what your API is no matter what
language you're writing it.
And so we looked around
at the different IDLs that
existed at that time and
we saw that Swagger really
had a lot of traction,
and we decided
that we would adopt
Swagger for this project.
And just about that time that
we started working with them,
they announced that
they were forming--
or they told us that they
were forming the open API
initiative.
So we became one of the
founding members of the open API
initiative, along with a lot
of other industry heavyweights,
and are now brothers
in arms apogee to join
this initiative that owns
the open API specification.
So we're using
the open API spec,
not just to describe
the surface of your API,
but also the config for how
you want us to manage it.
So you use extensions in
the open API spec to say,
hey, these methods need
auth, or use an API key here,
and we really like that.
We really think it's a
powerful and kind of imperative
way for you to describe the way
you want us to manage your API.
We also work with gRPC.
Anyone here using gRPC yet?
A few.
Anyone heard about gRPC?
This transport that we're
using heavily for our own APIs?
Well, if you are using
gRPC, then you'll
find that there's
probably really
only one proxy out
there that is really
doing API management with it.
You can define your
API in proto for gRPC,
and then you give us a yaml that
describes the configuration,
again, how you want us to
manage it, what sort of auth
you want, and we'll manage
your gRPC APIs as well.
Speaking of standards,
for authentication
we've chosen JSON Web
Tokens, which are pronounced
"Jot" for non-obvious reasons.
But JWTs and open ID
connect has kind of
become a standard
for authentication,
and that's where we're using
for authentication as well.
We've got a couple of providers
that we're working with.
It's a standard.
You can write them
yourself, but if you're
using Firebase or Auth0,
we can validate those.
And that's all I
wanted to get through,
and now I want to
hand this over to Sep,
who's going to show us
how the whole thing works.
SEP EBRAHIMZADEH: Great.
Thanks, Dan.
So as Dan mentioned,
we have the best demo
of the conference
saved for last.
I just hope that it works.
What I would like to show you
is a simple Node.js backhand.
Let's actually switch back
to the slides for a moment.
That implements a
rest API and I'll
show deploying that rest
API onto App Engine Flex.
And then I'll talk
about how we can
turn this backend
into an endpoint API
and we'll see what benefits
we get from that in terms
of the features
that Dan mentioned,
namely logging and monitoring.
And then the focus of the
talk is authentication.
So we'll talk about
how to secure that API
and make it so that all the
clients who want to call it
have to provide
authentication tokens.
And I'll talk about what
the clients would look
like in a different language.
So imagine that the Node.js
backend is one of my services,
and on the other side,
on the client side,
I'll have a Python application.
And the Python application
wants to call the Node.js APIs.
I'm not sure what that code
would look like from GCE.
If you want to run it from the
Google Compute Engine or any
of the other computer platforms
that GCP has, and I'll also
show similar code that
runs from outside of GCP,
or from my laptop, and we'll
talk about the trade offs.
So with that, let's go
to the code, please.
DAN CIRULI: Sep, you did a good
job of not interrupting me.
I promise not to do so.
SEP EBRAHIMZADEH: That's OK.
If you want to heckle
or you have questions,
feel free to interrupt me.
So let's take a look
at the node code first.
It's very simple,
about 20 lines,
and it's based on
Node.js Express.
So we have a few lines here
that define a rest API.
It's a post method for the
API that I've called echo.
It basically expects
some JSON content
to come as the request that
validates that it is JSON,
and it just returns that.
It calls it back
in the response.
Now, you could have
multiple other methods here
and expand your
API to get calls,
post calls, delete calls,
or multiple different paths
for whatever your
application might be.
And there's nothing Google
specific about this.
You could write the same exact
code in any other language.
You could write it in Node.js
without using Express.
I'm mentioning that to emphasize
the fact that with Endpoints
you will be able to use
any language that you want,
any framework that you want.
You're not limited
to a certain number
of languages or frameworks.
So that's all with the code.
Let's go back and think about
from the client's perspective,
what we need to
communicate to the client
to be able to call this API.
We are surely not going to
share the Node.js implementation
code with them.
And any documentation we
provide them is probably
going to be out of
date and not convey
the full message of what's in
the contents of the request,
what they should expect
in the responses.
For that, we will use open API.
The open API spec for this
simple API that has one method
is also rather simple.
It has one path for
the echo method.
It shows that it's
a post method.
And then it has some
documentation specific fields
like description that can
be parsed by open API tools
like the Swagger
UI, and it can also
be used to generate client
libraries for calling this API.
The rest of it is about what
the responses would look like.
A 200 response is defined
to have this type of message
in it, an echo message.
And the echo message
at the bottom
is defined here as a
message that has a field
and that field will have
a string value on it.
So you know, rather simple.
I just want to draw your
attention to the host field,
here.
I've named the API,
echo-api-without-auth.
At the endpoints, keyword
after is a reserved keyword.
Then you see my project ID,
the Google Cloud project ID.
So the name of this
APIs unique because it's
scoped into the project
IDs that are unique
and I can have multiple
different endpoints to APIs
in one project.
DAN CIRULI: If I want
to, can I serve this
from a different URL?
SEP EBRAHIMZADEH: You can, yes.
This is not the DNS
record that you'll
be calling your API with.
Because you might want
to have your endpoints
API be backed by basically
backends deployed
on different compute
platforms at the same time.
For the sake of this demo,
I'll be deploying on App Engine
Flex, but you might want
to deploy on Google Compute
Engine, or basic Kubernetes on
other cloud providers, or even
you on-prem data centers,
and endpoint should
work in all of those scenarios.
So let's go out of this open API
spec and run a gcloud command
and gcloud, as I'm sure you're--
who's used gcloud before?
Great.
Now, gcloud, as I'm
sure you're aware,
is the CLI for almost all
of Google Cloud products
and I'll be running
this gcloud command that
uploads the open API
specification to the control
plane for endpoints.
So I'm running gcloud
service-management deploy
and an openapi.yaml.
So what's happening
right now is the open API
is sent to the control plane.
The control plane takes a
look at it and validates it.
So it looks for any mistakes
in it, inconsistencies,
it also compares it to a
style guide that we have
and we've published as
the style guide for how
to design your APIs so that
they're hopefully future proof
and they're consistent.
And after it's done persisting
this copy of the open API spec,
it will return a unique
identifier for that copy of it.
In case I go to make changes to
my local copy of the open API
spec, this immutable
instance of it
is persisted on
the control plane.
So if anyone's used
App Engine Flex before,
you'll know that it has an
app.yaml sample configuration
file that basically
tells App Engine
and tells gcloud what runtime
environment it should use.
In this case, it's not
js, and the environment
is Flex because
the same command is
used to deploy to App Engine
Standard and App Engine Flex.
All I've added to this
app.yaml file in order
to turn endpoints
on is three lines,
and the three lines are
endpoints_api_service,
the name that I draw your
attention to in the open API
file, and the unique config_id.
So for the demo, I'll be showing
two different endpoint services
side by side so we
can compare them,
but let me paste this here.
Let's copy it again
and paste it here.
So this is what Dan was talking
about with deep integration
into App Engine Flex.
This conflagration
is all I have to add
and I can go and deploy
my App Engine app
the same standard
way that I always do.
DAN CIRULI: Wait for
the gcloud app deploy.
SEP EBRAHIMZADEH: Yeah, sorry.
And anyone who's used App
Engine Flex will tell you
that this will take quite
a few minutes to finish,
but I want to draw your
attention to the URL
that it spits out at the
end to say the deployment
has completed.
Then you can call your
backend at this address.
So I'm going to cancel
this because I've already
deployed it and I don't know
what to keep you waiting.
And instead, I'll do a curl
command against the already
deployed endpoint.
So it's curl.
It has a single header that
says the application JSON is
the format of the request.
And I'm sending it some data.
It says message and
Hello Next 2017!
So sure enough, the
backend is deployed.
It returns the same
data that I sent it.
DAN CIRULI: Wow, that's awesome.
SEP EBRAHIMZADEH: Thank you.
This part of it you could have
done even without endpoints.
So why did we upload
the open API spec?
What did we get in addition to
what we could have done before?
Well, let's go to
the developer console
and navigate to
the endpoints tab.
Endpoints alongside with
Compute Engine, App Engine,
has its own page on
the developer console,
and you can see the different
endpoint services I have.
This first one is the one
we've looked at so far.
It's a echo-api-without-auth.
So let's go to that one.
You can see that in
monitoring dashboard
as well as log
messages, have already
been propagated for
this endpoints API.
Now the metrics and the logs
that are being published
are API specific.
There are latencies
that were basically
measured for each request.
There are error ratios
as well as response codes
in the metrics.
And at the bottom
here we have links
to the logs that were
published for these requests.
So if I click on
one of these links,
it'll take me to
Stackdriver logging
and I can take a look at
one of the structured log
messages that was
published and see
that it has a JSON payload that
shows that the HTTP method was
a post, the URL was
the echo method,
and it has API
specific information
about the request size, response
size, and latency, and so on.
I could spend the rest
of the talk just playing
with Log Viewer here
because it's pretty cool.
Who's used Log Viewer before?
Great.
So you guys already
know about it.
DAN CIRULI: So people
who are using App Engine
are used to getting request log,
but if you're running something
in Compute Engine today,
this doesn't come for free.
You're not getting
this if you're
using Container Engine
or Compute Engine.
But by putting endpoints
in front of your API,
you are going to all
of a sudden-- you're
going to be getting logs for
every API call that comes in.
And the dashboard
that Sep showed
has some graphs that looks
similar to what you see in App
Engine, but what he
showed at the bottom
is it's all broken
down by method.
So you can not just see,
hey, the 98th percentile
say for our API is high.
You might see there's just
one particular method that
has a latency that's
high or that's
getting increased
the error rates.
So it's giving you
a higher fidelity
of metrics and a
higher fidelity of logs
because we know about your API.
SEP EBRAHIMZADEH: Exactly that.
So that's pretty cool.
We just uploaded our
open API specification,
which we were going to
write anyways in order
to communicate the surface
of our API to our clients,
and we got monitoring
and logging effortlessly.
But the focus of the
talk is authentication.
As you noticed, I made the
curl command from my laptop,
and this API is open
on the public internet.
Whoever has this URL
can go call it now.
So how do I secure it?
I have multiple
options for doing that.
I could go and write a lot
of Note.js code in order
to expect authentication
tokens and the requests that
are coming in, and
basically verify
the signature of those
authentication tokens,
and do all the hard work myself.
Or I can configure endpoints
to expect and require
authentication for my API, and
not make any backend Node.js
changes.
So which one seems
like the easier path?
Let's take a look at
the other open API
file that I have here to
illustrate how many lines
we've added, and the first
section is all the same.
The only thing I've changed
is the name of the API,
which is to say it's
echo-api-with-auth this time.
The rest is all the same,
except at the bottom
I've added about 10 lines.
The lines I've added--
first, there's a
security definition,
which is an open API
concept, and the name I've
given it is google_id_token.
And I've given it a
few different fields.
The important one to call
out here is that for the demo
I'm using the Google
identity provider,
and the issuer I'm configuring
is accounts.google.com.
Now, we will talk about other
identity providers and identity
provider hubs like
Auth0, Firebase,
and other third parties
that we support,
as well as custom JWT after
this part of the demo.
The second part, if you're
familiar with open API,
is simply saying that this
google_id_token security
definition should
be required for all
the methods in this API.
Alternatively, I could
have required just some
of the methods to have
authentication and keep
the rest either open, or
have multiple security
definitions here and say these
methods require that security
definition, those other methods
require another security
definition.
So we'll talk about why
that might be useful.
But let's exit this and do
the same thing we did before,
gcloud service-management.
Deploy this open API
specification to the endpoints
control plane.
At the end, so after a few
seconds, once it finishes,
it will give me a
configuration ID
and it has persisted this
version of my open API spec.
And what I'll do with that,
I'll copy the configuration ID
and I'll put it in the
application.yaml file
for App Engine, just
like I did previously.
You'll notice of
warning message here.
This is one of the
validations that it's doing.
It's saying that the echo method
is not protected with API keys.
It's asking if I'm sure
that I want to put this up
because then it would
be publicly accessible
and it doesn't know
that I have security
requirements on this method
with security definitions,
but that's the nice thing
about having your open API
spec validated.
You can see any warnings and
errors associated with it.
So let me copy this
conflagration ID,
put it in the app.yaml again.
I'll comment the
echo-api-without-auth section
and un-comment this section.
And again, I will
do gcloud app deploy
to deploy the same backend.
Remember, we have not changed
the Node.js code at all.
And I want to compare
them side by side
so perhaps I won't promote
it to the production
version of my app,
and maybe I'll
give it a different version.
Let's call it with-auth.
And once this
finishes deploying,
it will give me a different URL.
The URL will be
with-auth, and the rest
is the same, that's why I gave
it a different version name.
So I've also deployed
this because I don't
want to keep you guys waiting.
Let's go ahead and issue
the same curl command
against this deployment.
And sure enough, this time
the call didn't go through.
I got an HTTP 401
error and the error
has a message in it that
says JWT validation failed.
Credentials were either
missing or invalid.
So that's pretty cool.
We just secured the API.
It now requires authentication
and my work here is done.
We can go home.
Or maybe we should also take a
look at the client side as well
and see how we can actually
securely call this API now.
Well, for the
client side, I will
demo two different scenarios.
Let's say you're running on
the Google Compute Engine
and you have a virtual machine
and you're running your Python
client there.
And then I will show
you what it means
to run it outside of the
Google Cloud platform
and either run it on
prem or from my laptop.
So let's go to the developer
console for Compute Engine
and I have a vanilla
GCE instance here,
and it's just sitting
there doing nothing.
So that's why GCE is
recommending that I can either
downsize it and save some money,
or improve its performance.
And let's SSH to this.
DAN CIRULI: This is one of my
favorite features, by the way,
of Cloud Console, is the
click the button to SSH in.
SEP EBRAHIMZADEH: Right.
And the nice thing about
running from a GCE instance
is that for making my
authenticated call,
I can take advantage of the
built in credential management
features that all of the
compute platforms on GCP have.
So I have a service
account, just
like the accounts that you and
I would have as human users.
The service account
has some credentials.
It has a private key
associated with it.
On this GCE virtual
machine, those private keys
for the service accounts
are readily available,
and I don't have to
worry about security
copying them around, or
rotating them, and so on.
Let's take a look at this
GCE client code that I have.
It's just a few
lines of Python code,
and hopefully it's
legible on the screen.
This is the service account that
it's using the credentials of.
Its next demo service account
at some URL that we have.
What it's doing is first it
is creating a JSON web token,
and the payload for this
JSON web token is here.
It has an issue at field
and an expiration field.
The important ones are that the
issuer is the service account.
The target audience is the
echo-api-with-auth endpoint
service that I want to call.
And then what the
code is doing is
it's signing this JWT with
the credentials of the service
account that it has access
to on the virtual machine.
Then it uses that signed_JWT
to call the Google ID provider
and get an ID token.
The ID token is
also another JWT.
It uses that JWT to
call the echo API.
So we'll talk about why
there is a two hop step here
and what the advantages and
disadvantages of doing that
are.
Let's go ahead
and test the code.
First, without authentication,
sure enough, we
get the HTTP 401 error and
I've added a simple flag here
that says auth is
true or yes, and it
is creating a signed_JWT.
It is obtaining an ID
token with that signed_JWT
and then it's calling the
echo API with that ID token.
Sure enough, there
request succeeds,
and it returns the
message that had sent it.
DAN CIRULI: And that and that's
kind of cool that had happened
is it is using its
credential management that's
available within GCE--
any of the compute platforms.
So you're not having
to maintain a secrets,
you're not having to
rotate keys, that's just
going to happen automatically.
You sign that JWT,
and it's going
to use the latest
credential, and that
will be validated by Google.
SEP EBRAHIMZADEH: Right.
And you might say,
well, I don't want
to run my Python client side
on a Google Compute Engine
instance.
I want to run it elsewhere.
You can do that too.
Let's go to take a look
at the service account
that I just used in the
Google Cloud Console.
So under the service
accounts page,
I have the next demo service
account that we just saw,
and I can create a key for it.
When I create the
key, the credentials
are downloaded to my machine.
Let's tale a look
at the credentials
and you'll see that it
has a private key in it.
So this is the
private key portion
and from this point on I will
be responsible for securely
distributing it to
any place that I
want to run my clients on,
and rotating it, and so on.
So let's close that and
let's go back to my prompt.
DAN CIRULI: And this
is your laptop prompt?
SEP EBRAHIMZADEH: And
this is my laptop.
DAN CIRULI: You're not
running in Compute Engine.
SEP EBRAHIMZADEH: Exactly.
This is outside of the
Google Cloud Platform.
It's on the Wi-Fi
that we have here.
And I have a slightly different
client code than in Python
for running locally.
Let's take a look at that.
Again, it creates a JWT.
The only difference
is this time it
signs the JWT with
the credentials
that I have locally
on my machine.
So I have the private key
in the service account
file that I will
pass into the script.
It signs the JWT with that.
It uses that signed_JWT
to get an ID token
and then it calls the
echo API that ID token.
DAN CIRULI: So the
thing to bear in mind
here is you can run
this code anywhere.
If you're calling from
on prem to Google,
you're calling from another
cloud provider to Google,
you have to get that key
there and you probably
have methods that you're
using for handling secrets
in each of those places,
but this file now, it's
an important file.
Anyone who has this has the
ability to call your service.
So on Google, you don't have
to worry about that when you're
calling, when your service--
what he's running in Python--
is running outside of Google,
you don't to
maintain the privacy
and secrecy of this file.
SEP EBRAHIMZADEH: Exactly.
So let's go ahead and test
this one out and sure enough,
the same thing.
If I don't give it
any credentials,
the call fails with an HTTP 401.
If I give it this service
account credentials file,
it will create a
signed_JWT, get an ID token,
and call the API
with that ID token.
So that's pretty cool,
but it shows the advantage
and disadvantage of running
your client side on the Compute
Engine, or App Engine, or
basically the other computer
platform that we have on GCP.
So, we can go back to
the endpoints dashboard,
and see the same graphs, and see
the APIs running side by side.
This is the endpoints
API with authentication
and I've been generating
some traffic against it.
So this one will
also have metrics
and it also shows
the 400 requests
that were rejected because they
didn't have authentication.
So with that, let's go
back to the slides, please.
So what did we just look at?
First, we looked at some
sample Node.js code,
and the code might
have easily been
written in a different language
or a different framework.
We showed that it
implemented a rest API
and we showed how easy it
was to write an open API
specification that describes the
methods, requests, responses,
and documentation for that API.
And that if you have
the open API spec,
you basically have an endpoints
API, and you can get metrics,
logs, and authentication
out of Endpoints for that.
And of course, we
saw that the calls
we made before we added
authentication succeeded.
Once we added authentication,
the unauthenticated
calls with curl, or with the
clients written in Python,
failed.
And the key point here is that
the response that was HTTP 401
came from the endpoints
extensible server proxy.
So those requests never actually
made it to the Node.js packet.
And of course, when we had
authentication JSON web tokens
the request succeeded and
the response was proxied back
from the Node.js backend.
The few lines of
code that we had
to the few lines
of configuration--
excuse me-- that we had to
add to the open API spec,
I'll repeat it here,
the issuer we chose
was the Google ID token issuer.
Now, why did we do that?
We did that so that any
service account on the project
that I was using would
be able to call the API.
You might say,
well, I don't want
to use the Google ID provider.
I might want to use a third
party provider like Auth0
or I want to sign my own JWTs.
Well, that's also possible
with the same configuration.
You just have to provide
two extra lines that
tell the extensible server proxy
where to get your JWT public
key and what the audiences
are for your JSON web tokens.
Now, the advantage
of doing this is
that you're no longer calling
the Google ID provider at all,
that you can create a signed
JWT and call your API directly
with that.
The disadvantage
is that anytime you
want to change the audiences,
or rotate your credentials,
or say change the
public key URI,
you would need to
redeploy your backend.
Let's look at the
differences between them.
The cool thing is
that you could have,
as I mentioned earlier, multiple
different security definitions
if you're using your
own signed JWTs.
And that way do a bit
of authorization too
to say the JSON web tokens
that have this audience
can only call these
methods in my API,
the JSON web tokens that
have those other audiences
can call all of my methods or
these other methods of my API.
And of course, the advantage
of running with Google ID token
and on GCP is that the
credential management,
that rotating of secrets,
is handled for you.
So with that, I'll
hand back to Dan,
who will talk about
Firebase, and Auth0,
and the other features
that Endpoints is planning.
DAN CIRULI: Amazing demo, Sep.
Amazing.
SEP EBRAHIMZADEH: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
DAN CIRULI: And before I
do that, I might point out
that one of the sessions you
elected to not go to right now,
and I just found
out this last night
is our good friend from
Vendasta-- they're customers
of ours who are in one
of these other rooms
right now giving a talk
on security at Vendasta.
And what they're
talking about is
service to service
auth using Endpoints.
So if you were torn
between the two,
you got pretty much the
same material in either one
because this is
exactly what they
do when calling cloud to cloud
and calling within Google.
So we've talked a lot about
service to service auth,
and we talked about service
accounts, or robotic accounts
as we call them.
But in that very
first diagram slide,
I showed a mobile device.
When a call is coming in
from that mobile device, what
you generally want to
know there is who's
holding that mobile device?
Who logged into that mobile app.
You guys have heard
a lot about Firebase.
Firebase is, of
course, a great company
that we acquired a
couple of years ago,
and I think they've
done a really good job
as an acquisition
at Google of kind
of maintaining a
strong identity,
and also finding a great
place within Google
and integrating well.
They've really integrated well
on that mobile developer--
all of this and the tools
that Google is producing,
they have done a good
job of consolidating them
under Firebase.
If you are using Firebase,
one of their features
is Firebase auth, and they
have good client libraries
that you can use in mobile
devices or web apps, that
let your users sign in.
And your users can sign in
with username and password,
they can choose their Google
auth, they can use Facebook,
or Twitter, a bunch of
different identity providers.
They have a good client
library experience for that.
Well, if you are using
Firebase and you'd
like to put some
logic and say run it
on App Engine or any of
our compute backends,
they of course, are sending
a JWT token as well,
and of course, endpoints
can validate that JWT token.
There's a third party
identity solution called Auth0
that lots of mobile
developers are using.
We work with them as well.
Configuration there, very,
very similar because it's
all JWT based.
You basically tell us who's
going to be issuing this,
and there you will put
your Firebase project ID,
and you give the standard
address for where
to get that public key, and we
can validate those JWT tokens.
So that's the
configuration you would
use for your mobile API, the
one that will be called directly
by that mobile device.
So that's the bulk
of the stuff that we
wanted to talk about and give
you a little overview of what
Endpoints is, talk
to you about why
service to service
authentication is important,
when you might use it.
Did want to give you a
glimpse of what's going
to be happening coming up.
We have a lot of users--
we went full beta, I
think, in September.
We've been GA since last month.
We've got a lot of
people using this.
The great thing about getting
users using your software
is they start to tell
you what's missing
and that's fantastic feedback.
So, we've talked a lot
about authentication.
Well, our users
want authorization.
We have a lot of
people asking about
that and so you can bet
we're thinking pretty
hard about what to do about it.
Also very fine control.
Sep mentioned, one of
the things you can do now
is you can control.
You might have some methods
that you require API keys
for and some not.
In his configuration, he
was applying that policy
to the entire API.
You can do that per
method, but people
want it even more fine control.
We have customers who define
resources within their API
and they want to control who
has access to what resource.
So if I've got my
bookshelves API,
maybe you get access
to the history section
and you get access to
the science section,
but I'm not going to
let you read history
or you read science.
So we're looking at ways we
might do that for our users.
Rate limiting comes up a
lot, especially for people
who are starting to
think about exposing
their APIs to third parties.
It's not such a big deal
with your mobile app.
You rarely want to deny
requests to your own API,
but when other people
start using your APIs,
then you do think about
denying your requests.
We have a lot of other features
that people are asking for
and that we're
starting to work on.
So this is an area that we're
really investing a lot in.
So keep your eye on the space.
And with that, I think you are
looking at the last slide you
will look at in Next 2017.
We both have Twitter accounts.
I pay attention to
mine a lot and I
ping him and make him pay
attention to his sometimes.
Feel free to hit us.
[MUSIC PLAYING]